angriff eigenlob verteidigung die
generaldebatte im bundestag die
regierung verteidigt ihre politik der
letzten monate das war ein
leidenschaftlicher streit über die
laufende krisenpolitik oppositionsführer
friedrich merz attackiert sofort dann
der kanzler olaf scholz r pariert
ihnen und ihrer regierung aber auch in
wirtschaftspolitischer hinsicht jeder
kompass ja man muss es leider sagen auch
in der wirtschaftspolitik fehlt dieser
bundesregierung jede fähigkeit zum
politischen strategischen denken
es ist schon erledigt bevor sie es
ausgesprochen haben
wenn sie können die hoch komplexen
fragen der energiepolitik und der
versorgungssicherheit unseres landes in
einer solchen existenziellen krise doch
nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann dem wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist sie aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aussicht auf erfolg hat
diese krise in dem
was nicht möglich gewesen ist denn die
cdu/csu ist die partei die die komplette
verantwortung dafür hat dass deutschland
ausstiegs entscheidungen getroffen hat
aus der kohle und aus der atomenergie
aber die niemals die kraft hatte in
irgendetwas einzusteigen sie warnt
unfair den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien verweist die türen sie haben ab
der kämpfe geführt gegen jede einzelne
anlage und jeder ab der kampf der
letzten jahre schadet unserem land noch
heute das paar sie da habe ich sie haben
vor einigen wochen mal gesagt wir hätten
kein strom problem wir hätten ein gas
problem wir sind mittendrin in einem
massiven stromproblem in diesem land und
sie haben es offensichtlich bis heute
nicht verstanden
wir kommen wohl durch trotz aller
anspannung durch diesen winter mit den
vorbereitungen die wir gemacht haben und
weil wir so früh angefangen haben als
noch gar nicht ein so großes problem
problembewusstsein in deutschland da war
darum sind wir jetzt in der lage dass
wir tapfer und mutig in diesem winter
hinein gehen können dass unser land das
überstehen wird das ist die sache die
wir gemacht haben es war also der
erwartete schlagabtausch zwischen stolz
und märz und wir haben einen sehr
emotionalen olaf scholz ihr erlebt
ungewohnt aufbrausen fast schon
schreiend bei uns im studio ins bild
politik chef jan schäfer wie kam er für
dich rüber tatsächlich in die ecke
gedrängt oder dann wirklich erfolgreich
verteidigt emotional war olaf scholz auf
jeden fall das haben wir gerade in den
bildern ja auch gesehen und er war
angefasst er war angefasst so friedrich
merz vor knapp zwanzig minuten geredet
hatte und natürlich wie sieht das für
ein oppositionsführer gehört eine
abrechnung hingelegt hat mit der politik
der regierung von olaf scholz das hat
ihn kanzler überhaupt nicht gepasst oder
hat fast fünf minuten lang zu beginn
seiner rede eigentlich nur auf friedrich
merz reagiert argumentieren und da kamen
halt viele viele starke emotionale sätze
dann wurde es etwas langweiliger muss
man sagen in der rede des
bundeskanzlerin hat er über das
entlastungsprogramm das dritte
entlastungsprogramm gesprochen und hat
da ausgeführt was die regierung alles
planen und hat danach aber immer wieder
ursachenforschung schuld
suche betrieben und hat natürlich oh
wunder wunder für ein spd kanzler die
schuld vor allem bei der cdu/csu
gefunden bei friedrich merz partei er
war selbst ja nicht in amt und würden
aber seine partei von angela merkel hat
dieses land 16 jahre regiert und er hat
olaf scholz versucht ganz massiv holt
für das energie debakel in dem wir uns
jetzt befinden abzuladen und apropos
energiedebatte friedrich merz wiederum
hat ja bundeswirtschaftsminister robert
habeck kritisiert hat auch ganz klar
noch mal das interview
thematisiert was gestern gelaufen ist
und da wollen wir jetzt mal einmal
reinhören
das sehen wir jetzt überall das leben
die darauf angewiesen sind dass die
menschen geld ausgeben blumenläden
bioläden leckereien gehören dazu dass
die wirkliche probleme haben weil ist
eine kaufzurückhaltung gibt und dann
sind die nicht insolvent automatisch
aber sie hören vielleicht auf zu
verkaufen und du hast nicht aufhöre zu
verkaufen und verdiene ich kein geld
mehr da muss ich die insolvenz anmelden
nach zwei monaten wenn dies nicht getan
habe habe ich in so würde man würde dann
insolvent werden wenn man mit der arbeit
immer größeres minus macht ja aber wie
würde denn kein größeres minus machen
wenn sie leute bezahlen aber dies wir
verkaufen also
wie soll man also ich hab es nicht
verstehe ich weiß doch automatisch eine
insolvenzwelle geben geben muss aber es
kann sein dass ich bestimmte geschäfte
nicht mehr rentieren und hier dann
eingestellt werden vielleicht werden sie
spielt er wieder aufgenommen das kann ja
sein also das ist dann ja keine
klassische insolvenz aber es kann sein
wenn wir keine abhilfe schaffen dass die
dass betriebe dakar ein
handwerksbetriebe reinigungsfirmen und
so weiter über dieses jahr dann die
wirtschaftliche betätigung einstellen
das ist eine gefahr und der müssen wir
begegnen
und auf diesen wirrwarr
wirtschaftsminister hat friedrich merz
reagiert in der bundestagsdebatte und da
waren wir auch ein
wenn sie können die hoch komplexen
fragen der energiepolitik und der
versorgungssicherheit unseres landes in
einer solchen existenziellen krise doch
nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann dem wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist sie aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aussicht auf erfolg hat
diese krise in dem mit verlaub wie
hilflos er habe sie in diesen fragen
sind das konnte man gestern abend im
deutschen fernsehen überwachen man kann
nur hoffen man kann nur hoffen dass
ein großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen unternehmer und vor
allem sehr bäckerinnen und bäcker um
diese uhrzeit schon im bett gelegen
haben und geschlafen haben um das nicht
mit ansehen mussten was sie da gestern
abend von sich gegeben man kann die
führung
friedrich merz kritisierte
bundeswirtschaftsminister haarberg hier
sehr stark und es gibt eine umfrage bei
uns auf der homepage bei bild und da
haben wir gefragt ob unsere leser dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister noch zutrauen
das ruder wieder herumzureißen die
energie krise zu meistern und das ist
nicht gut ausgefallen das wunder wunder
muss man auch sagen nach dem auftritt
gestern bei maischberger fast 95 prozent
derjenigen die abgestimmt haben und das
sind zu diesem zeitpunkt fast
hunderttausend nutzer von bild.de hier
sehen wir als 93 prozent sind es genau
sieben prozent sagen ja herberg wird uns
gut durch die krise bringen 93 prozent
sagen nein wie gesagt bei rund 100.000
user die schon abgestimmt haben ist das
natürlich ein deutliches urteil das war
jetzt eine wirklich gute einfache
vorlage für friedrich merz ein elfmeter
den er auch verwandelt hat aber die
frage die dahinter steckt ist natürlich
in wirklichkeit wie wie solide sitzt
robert habeck da im
wirtschaftsministerium ist er wirklich
der mann mit genügend fachwissen mit
genügend kenntnisse um deutschland als
wirtschaftsminister durch diese krise
mit zu steuern und ehrlicherweise habe
ich da schon länger meine zweifel aber
wir sehen jetzt doch immer mehr dinge
auftritte auch die wirklich ein stark
daran zweifeln dass man hat fast den
eindruck das wirtschaftsministerium ist
so etwas wie ein krimi zentrum wo man
sich erstmal über monate ausprobieren
kann nein das ist es nicht das ist kein
training zentrum in dem anprobieren kann
testen kann was einem spaß macht das
funktioniert nicht dieses
wirtschaftsministerium ist ein zentrales
ministerium gerade dieser krise es wurde
geführt von wirklich schillernden
figuren ludwig erhard otto graf
lambsdorff karl schiller und jetzt sitzt
robert habeck der und man hat ja er
tüftelt ein bisschen probiert aus liegt
daneben die kinder nehmen und kann nicht
mal erklären was eine insolvenz ist das
ist für diesen standort eine echte
gefahr stolz sagt auch unterschätzen sie
nicht deutschland jetzt in dieser krise
unterschätzen sie nicht die bürgerinnen
und bürger in der krise würde man sich
immer erfolgreich unterhaken und dann
würde man das schon alles schaffen you
never walk alone sein ikonischer satz
ist dem so also ich meine cook bei den
aktuellen preisen nicht gerade jeder er
auf sich und sein portemonnaie lassen
sich mit solchen worten mit solchen
ansprachen rechnungen bezahlen ich kann
verstehen dass der bundeskanzler eine
beschwörende rhetorik nutzt in dieser
krise denn wir wissen das könnte
durchaus sehr sehr ungemütlich werden in
den nächsten monaten nicht nur für die
privaten haushalte die ist jetzt ja auch
schon spüren anhand der gas und der
stromrechnung sondern auch für viele
viele unternehmen und da ist es
zumindest aus politischer sicht
verständlich dass ein bundeskanzler so
argumentiert er muss aber glaube ich
bloß aufpassen dass er nicht da den
bezug zur realität verliert denn wir
werden uns unterhaken dass es schön
gesagt aus dem plenarsaal des deutschen
bundestages aber viele viele menschen
spüren ja jetzt schon dass sie
eigentlich am ende des geldes noch monat
übrig haben also wie kommen sie über die
runden firmen wie kam es gestern
vernommen hatte der große corona
gewinner muss man sagen der clou
papierhersteller ist plötzlich pleite
also es gibt jetzt firmen die wirklich
dramatisch abstürzen wegen dieser hohen
gaspreise beim bäcker hat angekündigt
zum dritten mal in diesem jahr die
preise zu erhöhen das heißt viele viele
produkte sind so viel teurer geworden
dass menschen sich das nicht mehr
leisten können ich glaube da fällt dann
fielen schwer in so einer krise zu sagen
wir haben uns mal unter und werden das
alle schon gemeinsam meistern ich glaube
da überwiegt eher der frust als die lust
sich unter zu haben
danke dir bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
zu der generaldebatte heute im bundestag
[Musik]